non là il y aura pas il y aura pas de
petit parce que faut qu'elle les couve
faut qu'elle le chauffe conseiller et
accompagner ce sont les missions que ces
données Tanguy à la tête de à chacun sa
poule une entreprise qui l'a créé il y a
3 ans ce jeune entrepreneur de 25 ans
s'est spécialisé dans les galinacés
il y a 3 ans et du coup bah le but moi
c'est de promouvoir la poule en ville
quand j'ai été petit que j'ai commencé à
avoir des poules
j'ai fait toutes les erreurs possibles
je savais pas du tout comment faire et
je me suis dit pour éviter que les gens
fassent ces erreurs bon autant les
accompagner sur ça donc c'est bien les
conseillé sur la construction de
l'enclos le poulailler comment voilà
essayer de à la fois avoir des poules
mais en même temps préserver aussi un
peu son jardin ils ont souvent des
questions sur les contraintes que ça
peut représenter
c'est vrai ah ouais t'as pas trop peur
depuis vraiment quand même 6 ans il y a
une nouvelle on va dire en tout cas en
ville voilà les gens demandent de plus
en plus à avoir des poules et un des
animaux les plus présents chez les
foyers c'est un français sur disque qui
a des poules chez soi une expertise qui
met au service des particuliers comme
des professionnels en 2021 Tanguy a aidé
à mettre en place et concevoir le
poulailler du parc Chanel de
Croissy-sur-Seine à la demande de la
mairie il en a sur le suivi toutes les
semaines
en fait le tourisme comme ça et après
c'est récupéré les œufs quand on a de la
chance il y en a j'ai débuté avec les
particuliers et maintenant je fais aussi
des installations dans les EHPAD les
écoles les collectivités là comme on
voit à Croatie parce que le but c'est
que ceux qui n'ont pas de jardin chez
eux qui peuvent pas avoir de poule
puisse en avoir dans d'autres lieux si
vous voulez
un animal qui va manger nos restes
alimentaires à peu près 75 kilos de
déchets organiques par an quand on va
s'occuper de sa poule dans son jardin
pourquoi on vient dans un parc regardez
les poules c'est un peu le temps qui
s'arrête on est vraiment avec les
animaux on les regarde on les observe
Tanguy livre ses poules issu d'un
élevage du Vexin tous les mercredis dans
les Yvelines
cette semaine de poules viennent
compléter le poulailler Doremi un
particulier de Morainvilliers une
troisième les rejoindra en mai avec une
particularité c'est une poule de
réformes
à Feucherolles il y a 2500 2600 poules
qui normalement sont mises à l'abattoir
au bout de 18 mois parce que elles sont
considérées comme moins productives et
là pour la deuxième année consécutive on
décide de les distribuer aux
particuliers parce que c'est des poules
qui pondent encore quatre semaines à peu
près qui peuvent vivre encore au moins
deux ans mes parents étaient paysans mon
grand-père était paysan et j'ai donc été
élevé avec des animaux tout ce qui est
poules canards et trucs comme ça il
meurent de la bonne mort ici mais je
suis content au contraire de là de
trouver et puis j'ai pris une réformée
parce qu'on en soit quand même une mai
plus de 2500 poules de réforme
rechercheront un foyer d'ici mai
prochain la poule devant moi est vendue
5 euros pour en réserver rendez-vous sur
le site internet de chacun sa poule